[Music]
so I'm going to be talking about this
cluster of sort of words that we inquire
about strategy policy governance
sometimes we say cooperation but I want
to first explain my preferred term which
is governance some people when they hear
governance they think regulation
governance is not just regulation in
fact regulation might be a very small
part of governance some people hear when
they hear global governance they think
world government that is also not does
not follow rather the term governance
just refers to the whole mess of
processes by which decisions are made
and so that includes laws regulations
policies but also institutions and norms
so we can beget begin provocatively with
what we might call one theory of AI
enabled governance which is from
Vladimir Putin whoever leads an AI will
rule the world alright so this is if you
will a theory of governance because it
says how decisions will be made under an
AI enabled future now before proceeding
it's worth marking that Putin was not
staring ominously into the camera when
he said it he was in fact encouraging
Russian schoolchildren to do their
science projects on robotics and other
topics what this quote really did
resonate around the world because I
think it tapped into a fear that many
people have that the sort of governance
of all things of the world could be
dramatically changed by AI that power
could shift a world order could change
and so that's why the question of the
governance of AI how decisions about AI
will be made are so important this leads
to the normative definition which is
that we don't just want to think about
what the processes are we want good
processes and by good we mean something
like effective legitimate inclusive
adaptive so I'm going to talk about a
lot of things it will not feel like I've
covered the whole space and that's
because I will have not done so and the
reason that that is the case is because
this problem is really hard the
governance of AI will not be easy we can
see this by thinking about the nature of
AI as a general purpose technology like
electricity the
printing press the combustion engine
these general-purpose technologies
transform society the economy military
in a deep fundamental way that's often
hard to anticipate and very hard to
govern so on the right hand side I list
some of the properties that are
plausibly the case with AI and each of
these makes it difficult to govern the
fact that the benefits in the harms are
so diffuse makes it hard for political
groups to mobilize together to address
those harms and to realize those
benefits the great uncertainty we have
about what kinds of capabilities are
coming and what the implications of
those capabilities will be makes it
again very hard to build appropriate
norms and regulations around it and so
on with the rest of these properties to
try to make sense of this at the Center
for governance of AI at the future of
humanity Institute we have been
beginning work on a whole host of
questions and part of that work has led
to this research agenda where we try to
articulate the main questions and
tractable ways into the problem and this
research agenda breaks the space up into
four categories the technical landscape
politics ideal governance and then
policy these four categories share a
mapping with the conference organization
so ideal governance is like the
destination right it's where we want to
get to if we could all sit around the
table and discuss calmly and rationally
what would we come up with politics
refers to you know the fact that it
won't be a calm rational patient
conversation around the table there will
be interest groups there will be
misunderstandings there will be
coalition's there will be institutions
with voting rules of different kinds and
that will shape what world we find
ourselves in so we want to understand
those political dynamics the technical
landscape refers to what are the sort of
technical constraints and possibilities
made possible by AI and other
technologies and then finally policy
refers to the lessons we draw from this
for what we should be doing tomorrow
what kinds of near-term steps can we
take to steer us towards beneficial AI
or AGI an analogy might help suppose we
were founding a city the technical
landscape is the geographic landscape
and perhaps the relative price of steel
and aluminium and concrete the politics
is again the interest groups the values
of different parties the coalition's the
voting rules ideal governance are the
blueprints we come together and
articulate for what the city could look
like and then policy is what we're going
to do tomorrow to make that happen I
want to begin by distinguishing between
two kinds of conservativism that I think
scientists especially it's helpful to
distinguish for them and I'll illustrate
that with a quote from Leo Szilard the
inventor of the neutron chain reaction
from the very beginning the line was
drawn Fermi thought that the
conservative thing was to play down his
10% possibility that a nuclear chain
reaction may happen while Dillard
thought the conservative thing was to
assume that it would happen and take all
the necessary precautions so as
scientists we don't want to make claims
statements that we can't support right
with theory and evidence and that's a
good virtue for scientific discourse but
for policymakers we want to take low
probability high-impact possibility
seriously because we don't some of them
will be realized and we won't be
prepared and so it's good to separate
while as scientists we want to be you
know calm and epistemically grounded
when thinking about extreme
possibilities from AI as policymakers we
want to allow ourselves the imagination
to think what could come in 5 10 15
years so we can prepare ourselves for it
so first I'll tell you a little bit
about the technical landscape but again
I'm just going to dip into it giving you
some examples of research we've been
doing so I there's a lot of questions in
the space we might ask for example what
are the kinds of powerful AI systems
that could emerge in the coming years
what are their strategic properties are
they say offense biased or defense
biased do they lend themselves towards
cooperation or do they increase
uncertainty in stochasticity and say
power where are the inputs and
capabilities in the world and how are
they changing inputs like compute
training data talent can we model a
progress AI progress so we can better
anticipate what in five or ten years the
landscape will look like who will be the
most prominent actors can we forecast
capabilities so some of the work that we
might call mapping was done by Nick
Bostrom and super intelligence looking
out into the future trying to see what
different advanced capabilities would
look like and what the implications are
some other mapping work is done by Jeff
reading in his report deciphering
China's AI dream
looking at what the current capabilities
are in China for various kinds of AI and
trying to forecast how that could change
into the future as well as what the
constellation of actors in China produce
in terms of goals for the country some
other work is done by Ben Garfinkel
looking at cryptography cryptographic
systems and we might simplify that and
say blockchain could do for global
coordination global order world order
and I highly recommend this report as
among the best analyses I've seen of
what these really exciting technologies
but also ultimately in many ways limited
technologies really do enable some other
work with that Ben has done is looking
at how the offense defense balance will
change as the amount of resources spent
by actors increases and this is relevant
to AI because if AI scales up the
resources available say for autonomous
weapons for cyber warfare then it could
change the character of conflict and
this really interesting result we found
was that for a number of different kinds
of conflict domains as resources scale
up the often see fence balance scales
towards the defensive it doesn't go all
the way necessarily to defense dominance
but it does become more defence biased
and there's a number of other
interesting questions again related to
the strategic properties of advanced AI
some other work is surveying AI
researchers at nerves and ICML and
others to try to get some data on what
the future might look like now of course
you shouldn't take these survey results
as especially sort of it's not from an
Oracle that knows the future but it is
one source of data and then we want to
complement that with other kinds of data
to try to get timelines I want to use
this visual metaphor to clarify how we
can think about AGI and and how we can
think about our work in governance
related to it so imagine so the the kite
the capability space or the task space
is high dimensional right 10 to the 10
to the 100 Anthony suggested yesterday
this I can only represent two dimensions
on this screen so let's collapse it to
two dimensions say physics research and
understanding humans AGI is not a point
in this space which some people might
you might think because it's a word
it suggests a single thing AGI is sort
of right here when you get to human
level on all capabilities rather AGI is
a cloud or you know a space the
northeast quadrant above this
intersection and the reason I'm
emphasizing that is that AGI is not one
thing it's it's a huge space of possible
kinds of technology AI systems right at
that intersection look very different
from AI systems up here or over here so
that again is it's just a reminder that
when we say AGI we're not describing a
particular system we have a clear vision
of mine now there's this other concept
of transformative AI which has different
definitions depending on who's using it
I might use it to mean when an AI system
that could radically change wealth power
or world order so when would we see
transformative AI we might graph it like
this and everything again northeast of
that and I think that's plausible
because once we have actual AGI systems
in this kind of simplest sense that's
very likely to be extremely
transformative but probably the
transformative implications will come
sooner
right and this suggests that we might
want to start from the present that we
understand relatively well and then try
to extrapolate out under different
pathways to the points where we see
extreme transformative possibilities
arising and that's what I'll describe
now under the politics section so this
is the big slide of some political
challenges from near-term AI and again
I'm just focusing on near-term AI
because they're easier to see but it's
under this logic that if we can see them
and understand them well we can
extrapolate out to when transformative
possibilities start hitting and towards
the implications of AGI and there's
really each of these items we could talk
about for an hour or day or a whole
conference so I'll just talk about a few
one that we will be having a panel on is
labor displacement and inequality that's
clearly a very big issue that already
many people in the world are concerned
about and AI and automation could
dramatically amplify and exacerbate
those concerns there's concerns about
influence right if algorithms are ever
more sophisticated at understanding our
psychology and inferring our psychology
from say the digital traces we leave on
Facebook and other online site
then what does that mean for the say the
balance of power between marketers and
citizen or consumers or between
governments and citizens another
political challenge that I want to
emphasize because most of these are sort
of gloomy or are suggest AI is
disruptive is that we might lose the
innovation in the progress that we're
seeing in AI if there's a fearful
backlash so if Trust in AI developers
and in governments that are sort of
sponsoring that is lost we could see a
backlash and clumsy policy that follows
and I'll share with you some survey
results that are going public at the end
of this conference to speak to this so
this was a survey of Americans and one
of the questions we asked was to what
extent they trust various actors to
develop or manage AI in the interests of
the public and some takeaways are you're
more likely to be trusted if you are the
US military or if you're academic
University researchers or scientists
you're moderately trusted if you're a
technology company unless your name is
Facebook and interestingly this survey
was actually done before the Cambridge
analytical scandal exploded so this a
loss of trust had been accumulating
you're moderately trusted if you're an
intelligence agency within the US
government but you are not trusted if
you're the federal government or state
government or the UN so this tells us
something about at least Americans
perspectives and we'll be surveying
Europeans and Chinese citizens going
forward to understand how people think
about the governments of AI another
interesting set of results we found
relates to the demographics of support
for developing AI and HL mi which here
you can think of it as almost a GI but
before showing you the results I want to
have you all sort of articulate your
prior about the results so first on
gender do you think men are more
supportive of AI and hom I or women so
everyone decide in your head and then
I'll have you raise your hands okay so
if you think men are more supportive of
a developing AI and HTMI raise your
hands okay and if you think women are
more supportive raise your hands so
strongly leaning towards men but some
are thinking women
and how about education do you think
more educated people are more supportive
of AI in HMI or less educated people so
raise your hands if you think more
educated people are more supportive okay
unless educated great so I'm very happy
that the room was it didn't have
consensus because then I can say that
there's value in the science that I'm
about to present so we will learn
something so the answer is the sort of
prototypical person who is more opposed
to AI is female less educated poor and
without computer science background or
experience and interestingly this is for
both AI and a and HL mi it correlates
pretty strongly some other less strong
results related to religion and
political partisanship for example so
this is one issue that hasn't broken yet
on partisan grounds though might
speaking to a point max made this
morning if we ask them about how sort of
hopeful they are about HTMI in this case
we asked them for the expected impact of
a chiller by you'll see twelve percent
chose extremely bad possibly human
extinction that's more more than double
the proportion that's said extremely
good so and then also unbalanced bad
outweighs ever so slightly unbalanced
good so Americans at least are not
thinking that AGI is going to bring
utopia or they're not convinced of that
and this is important for a few reasons
one these might be legitimate concerns
that it would be good to address but to
this level of sort of negative
expectation about what AGI means for for
them and for Humanity could again lead
to that backlash could lead to
resistance to all the possibilities in
the up side that we see so I think this
is something we should you know be
taking very seriously
okay so there's number of other issues
again I'm just going to jump in a report
from early 2018 was the malicious use of
AI report which many of you may have
seen looking at the many ways that AI
enables new sort of malicious actions
again it's not to say that AI is net
negative but it's worth being attentive
to those possibilities
another new paper
by Nick Bostrom is the vulnerable world
hypothesis which asks if technology
becomes especially destructive so if one
person could cause a lot of harm
because enabled by new technology what
does that mean for world order and for
sort of the ideal governance among these
many issues I think there's an
underlying issue which I and others
focus on which is competition between
firms countries and especially great
power security competition I see this as
an amplifier and something that
exacerbates many of these other issues
and even issues like privacy which you
might think is an issue that a country
can figure out for itself right a
country well governed country say Sweden
should be able to formulate its own
optimal policies with respect to privacy
what competition puts constraints or at
least it forces on them trade-offs that
they might not want to make for example
the EU I might want to have stronger
privacy legislation but if they do that
they're worried that they will have
difficulties cultivating new AI
companies and AI champions so now they
face this trade-off between economic
prosperity and there are sort of
preferred values and how algorithms are
deployed and this I think applies to
almost all of these issues that
competition between countries and
especially competition that touches on
security national security concerns
makes it much harder to solve these
problems I want to also complicate two
metaphors that we often use for
understanding risks from AI so we often
talk about them as coming from accidents
or coming from misuse right so an
accident is something that arises
because the engineers weren't careful
enough or they didn't spend enough time
looking at the system or maybe the
science was insufficiently developed or
maybe the the machinery is very
complicated and so it's accident-prone
whereas misuse is the kind of harm that
comes from some malicious actor usually
a rogue actor a terrorist or criminal
who gets their hands on the technology
and then deploys it in a way that's
against society's preferences these two
perspectives are really useful but
they're incomplete and in fact I think
they miss a lot of the variation and
where risk comes from and also a lot of
the opportunities for policy
intervention so Remco and I suggest a
structural perspective which focuses on
these various structural prop
of society politics the economy that are
more likely to generate risks and I have
here John F Kennedy during the Cuban
Missile Crisis as the sort of exemplary
image because I don't think we would
call the Cuban Missile Crisis an
accident right it's not that the nuclear
weapons systems were poorly built
leading to the crisis
nor was it a case of misuse it wasn't a
terrorist or some rogue actor outside
the sort of legitimate political order
that led to the crisis rather it was the
legitimate leaders of two great powers
who found themselves at the brink of
nuclear war because of structural
strategic properties of the
international system so I think a lot of
our thinking has to be much more
structural to really grasp where the
risks come from we're looking at the
levers of influence that the US
government for example would have over
AI companies in the industry and vice
versa
to try and understand what the strategic
game could look like in the future we're
also looking at historical examples of
attempts to control powerful technology
like in this case depicted the
conversations after World War two to
control nuclear weapons so many of us
weren't aware of this there was a
serious conversation that took place
about the u.s. giving up nuclear weapons
to the UN in order for there not to be
an arms race in nuclear weapons this
conversation did not succeed but there's
a lot of interesting lessons about how
that took place including number one
that scientists can play an extremely
important role politically and also
enabling cooperation such as by finding
technical possibilities that would
otherwise be overlooked okay so moving
on to ideal governance in many ways this
is the work that I think's been least
done so far and I applaud Max for in
both his book but also at the two
conferences Asilomar and here really
trying to have us articulate what are
these positive visions that we can look
towards some work that we've done at FHI
is this paper policy to zero to zero
rata for super intelligent AI where we
tried to articulate what are things that
are what are sort of features that
become more important in a world of
advanced machine intelligence and some
other work is again from the survey that
is going to be public in a few days
where we asked Americans what are the
governance challenges that they regarded
as most important and most likely and
the takeaways here are one they regard
them all
pretty important so the bottom of this
figure is 2.5 that's somewhere between
somewhat important and very important
and the other takeaways that there is
variation and how Americans perceive
these governance challenges data privacy
cyber tax and surveillance standout is
among the more salient to them and
finally it's good to do this work this
research but it's even better if we can
translate that into policy
recommendations for the near term so
I'll tell you about one this is called
the windfall clause this was first
articulated in Nick's book and the idea
is if some actor some company wins the
AI windfall wins the AI lottery right
they become this super corporation with
the best AGI that's capturing all the
markets it would be good if they
redistributed a lot of that wealth to
the world to humanity and the idea
behind this proposal is that it could be
a legally committing obligation that
they would voluntarily undertake now
before when they're far away from this
windfall to give away the bounty in the
event that they happen to win the
lottery and what's really exciting is
that legally it seems to be permissible
under Delaware law to make this
contractual commitment so long as the
expected costs at the time of the
commitment are less than ten percent of
national annual taxable income so the
basic idea is as long as that you're not
giving away too much right away and
you're not but if the risk is
sufficiently high that you're gonna win
or the probability sufficiently high or
low that you're gonna win then it's
tolerable to shareholder to share value
I mean shareholders don't have a legal
basis to sue against that so in summary
there's a lot of important questions and
work to be done and but what's great is
there's a lot of talent that's pouring
into this field working on these
projects so I look forward to in the
coming years working with many of you to
answer these questions Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]